literally I I am the biggest e-news
fanatic always have been you always
bring the goods we are here at the news
desk to hit some amazing pop culture
headlines and I just cannot wait to dive
in let's do shall we get started okay
all right first up stranger thing actor
Millie Bobby Brown announced her
engagement to Jake Bon Jovi in a social
media post captioned with Taylor Swift
lyrics reading I loved you three Summers
now honey I want them all I mean and I
heard by the way that like Taylor
actually responded is this true I mean
how amazing is that right did she really
respond in the comments she didn't
respond in the comments now let me let
you guys know something when I first
read this I thought I am 36 and still
talking to my plants I can't even get a
text back and Millie Bobby Brown is
getting engaged yeah but and I know a
lot of people say she's young and maybe
she's moving too fast but we have to
remember that when you're a child star
and you've been in this business for
that long your life your maturity level
you have lived so much so her 19 is our
29. and no one said she's getting
married at 19. she's getting engaged
right now well I support it and just for
the fact that her name would be Billy
Bobby Brown Bon Jovi I'm okay with that
I like
I'm here for it
all right you guys remember you remember
this documentary uh and the entire fire
Festival yeah right that was a disaster
it was a Netflix documentary a few years
back there are two documentaries about
it it's that Festival that everybody got
like summoned to and thought they were
going to this like Elite amazing Resort
sort of Coachella on an island type of
sit sure which ended up being Survivor
yeah like totally worse totally it was
such an epic failure that documentaries
were made about it so you know you you
know what you do if you have one Epic
disaster you do it again
the festival's Creator Billy McFarland
has announced fire Festival 2 is on its
way the first firefest was like we said
it was a nightmare he was actually
arrested and charged with fraud so this
news has raised some eyebrows to say the
least my question is who's going wait is
it the same guy who's putting it on yes
so this is
yeah oh do you really want to be a part
of this man's Redemption
I'm good do you know what I'm nosy okay
and I kind of sort of want to see what
he does personally I might go with a
camera crew I was just gonna say I think
it's a really good opportunity to like
document and maybe make documentary
number three well Netflix is definitely
going to do it they're definitely going
to follow him they have not confirmed it
okay but they love this kind of stuff my
whole thing is Billy before you go to
fire Festival part two can you just like
plan up our mitts for here in New York
best practice you know what I mean put
on a show somewhere come on why do we
need a truck everybody to an island
where you don't even have water yeah
let's just do a block party keep it
simple okay who here raise of hands
would go to fire Festival to knowing
what you know you're a lot of fun the
hand up you're a lot of fun wait we can
room together
hi what's your name Corey okay Corey um
why would you go may I ask well just out
of curiosity I didn't see what it was
all about and see whether or not you
know we actually pulls it off and go
through with it yeah bring bottled water
okay of course I was gonna say I think
rations are required maybe it needs to
be treated like um you know uh wild
starring uh Reese Witherspoon you know
like you need like a full you know
supply of food and shelter and you know
just you know have a resource available
yeah exactly I'm taking Bear Grylls with
me as my as my bunk man I love him I
love him too I love you Justin so faster
we love you catch Justin on E news as I
do Monday through Thursdays at 11 p.m on
E and up next the beautiful Katie Holmes
is here we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign